Professor Robert Shiller:
Next Wednesday we're having
David Swensen lecture to us.
He heads up the Yale
endowment--or the investment of
the Yale endowment--and I have a
New York Times article on
the syllabus,
just sort of a biography of him
you could read.
On reserve, I have his recent
books, so I hope that you will
get a lot from him.
I misspoke, he's not a Yale
college graduate,
he's a Yale Economics PhD;
his undergraduate was from
University of Wisconsin but he's
been at Yale a very long time.
He came to Yale from Wall
Street in 1985 and at that time
the Yale endowment was worth
about one billion dollars.
It is now, under his
leadership, $22.5 billion and
that explains a lot of the
quality of your life because
that means we have about $2
million dollars per student.
The interest on $2 million
dollars is--what is that?
I can't even do
division--$100,000 a year.
So that's why Yale is much more
generous with financial aid than
other universities and why we
have beautiful--of course,
this room was built,
I believe, in the 30s.
Don't thank David Swensen for
this room but for a lot of other
things.
So Yale had a 28% return on its
portfolio last year,
which was number one of all
college endowments.
Moreover, it's had a 17.8%
average return for the last ten
years, which is number one among
university endowments.
We beat Harvard,
we beat Princeton,
but actually Princeton was--the
head of the Princeton endowment
is a protégé
of David Swensen and I'm sure
these people get together and
talk.
All of the major
universities--Harvard has been
doing very well too and so have
Duke,
MIT, Amherst,
a lot of--it seems that
universities manage to invest
very well,
at least they have in recent
decades.
I think that has--my
theory--that has something to do
with the intellectual atmosphere
at universities.
That is, investing well
requires careful study and the
intellectual tradition we have
at universities helps promote
that.
I don't know if David Swensen
can continue to do this.
I think we're--he's had a
spectacular return,
but he's getting into a
challenging year.
This is a year of financial
crises, so I'm warning you ahead
that--don't expect a 28% return
on the Yale portfolio for the
coming year.
You can ask him about that.
If he can do it again in this
situation, it will be amazing.
That would be next Wednesday.
Meanwhile, I want to talk today
about regulation.
Wow, I think we're
alright--something needs more
regulation here--all these
wires.
I want to motivate regulation
in terms of the last lecture.
Our previous lecture was about
behavioral finance and it was
about human failings.
I think that we to motivate a
lot of our regulation of
financial markets by the kinds
of errors that people make.
I wanted to list a few errors
that are well-known and that are
exploited by unscrupulous people
in finance.
I think they motivate a lot of
what--I'm going to write a
number of principles of
behavioral finance down and just
mention them briefly and then
return to regulation.
These are things from the field
of psychology.
Wishful thinking.
This refers to the fact that
people--this sounds like
something you probably already
know but it has been documented
by psychologists.
People tend to make the error
of believing what they want to
believe.
For example,
people tend to believe that
their team will win;
this has been documented by
psychologists.
They have a bias.
If you ask them,
what's the probability that
Yale will win the Yale-Harvard
game,
don't expect Yale students or
Harvard students to give an
unbiased probability.
You tend to,
in your mind,
think that you're going to win.
This also applies to
elections--we just had a primary
yesterday.
People tend to assume that the
candidate that they believe in
will win.
So, it's well-known and this is
something that can be exploited
by people selling investments.
Second thing:
attention anomalies.
These are--human attention
tends to be sporadic.
That is that you--the errors
that people naturally make are
often errors of inattention.
You look at certain things and
you overly--you pay too much
attention to some things and too
little to others.
This is something that
psychologists have been talking
about for over a hundred years.
Human attention is part of
human intelligence.
We have to know what to pay
attention to People who are not
good in focusing their attention
on the right things--I'm not
just talking about attention
deficit disorder,
I'm talking about some more
high-level question of how you
know what you should be paying
attention to.
Under attention,
there's a social basis for
attention and that is that
people tend to pay attention to
what other people are paying
attention to.
It's easy to sweep things under
the rug and get people to forget
something.
The kinds of things that are
naturally talked about get
excessive attention and the
details tend to get forgotten.
Three is anchoring.
This refers to a tendency for
people in making quantitative
judgments to subconsciously have
their judgments anchored by some
arbitrary stimulus.
I mentioned overconfidence last
period;
we then tend to have
overconfidence in our anchored
judgments.
The classic experiment that
demonstrated anchoring was
Kahneman and Tversky--I'm
writing K&T--in a wheel of
fortune experiment,
which they did in 1974.
What they did was they got
subjects to participate in a
psychological experiment and the
experiment consisted of asking
the subjects questions that had
quantitative answers,
which were always numbers from
zero to one hundred.
Then they said,
I'm going to ask you a question
but before you answer the
question I'm going to spin a
wheel of fortune.
You know what a wheel of--it's
like one of those things on quiz
shows.
You spin this big wheel and it
rotates for a while and then it
stops at one number,
but obviously a random number,
because this wheel of fortune
had all the numbers from zero to
one hundred.
One of the questions they asked
was, what percent of African
nations belong to the United
Nations?
That apparently is a difficult
question that most people didn't
know in 1974.
The way they did it--they said,
we'll ask you the question and
think about it,
but while you're thinking about
it--don't answer yet--we're
going to spin this wheel of
fortune.
So it comes up with a random
number then they asked for the
answer.
Well, it turns out that people
tended to give an answer close
to the number that came up on
the wheel of fortune.
Now, they perfectly well knew
that the wheel of fortune was
random.
So, the experimenters,
after they got the number,
they'd say, hey your number is
almost the same as the number
that just came up.
People would--and they would
say, did you just give me the
number that came up?
And people would deny it.
They would say,
oh no I wasn't influenced by
that number.
The point of anchoring is that
you are subconsciously
influenced by numbers and it
affects your judgment;
you think you know.
For example,
in looking at a stock,
if you ask people to predict a
stock market price they think of
some number that they saw before
and they are overly influenced
by that number.
For example,
in the late 1990s,
if you were to ask a
question--I'm hypothesizing--how
likely is it that the Dow will
be over 10,000 by the year 2008?
People might give that a low
probability because it had never
been over 10,000,
so they just had no
psychological anchoring on that
number.
Once it passes 2000,
then it seems completely
natural;
that's anchoring.
Related to this is the
representativeness
heuristic.
It seems to me that if you type
this you'll get a spell check
error.
And that's Kahneman and Tversky
again and it's related to
anchoring in some sense.
What it means is that--it
refers to a human tendency to
judge events on the basis of
similarity to other events that
are prominent in our mind
without regard to the actual
probability of the event.
I'll give you--in one of
Kahneman and Tversky's examples,
people were asked to judge the
occupation of a young woman.
They had a description of the
young woman and the woman was
described as sensitive,
artistic, etc.
The occupation choices that
they were allowed were:
bank teller,
sculptress, or something else.
Many people chose sculptress
because they thought,
well if she's a sensitive,
artistic woman maybe she's a
sculptress.
But that is a terrible mistake
because we should know that
sculptresses are very rare;
very few people have the job of
a sculptress or sculptor,
so it's a mistake.
What it means is that people
will--what it means is--[I have
to stuff this wire in my
pocket]--that we sometimes
exaggerate in our imagination
some rare event and it colors
out thinking.
For example,
the stock market crash of 1929
is repeatedly re-expected even
though it only happened once;
it's just prominent in our
thinking.
People are looking at stock
prices to see patterns that they
remember that are prominent in
their thinking and then those
patterns are given an
exaggerated probability.
When we looked at the random
walk series--I think the
representativeness heuristic
played a role in there as well.
When you look at a random walk
you have the intuitive
impression that you can
extrapolate it--that it doesn't
look like--you can't believe
it's really random,
but the reason you can is
because you overweigh the
probability of certain things
that caught your attention.
There are some more.
Five is gambling
behavior.
Anthropologists have found that
gambling is present in all human
cultures.
Not that everyone gambles but
there will be--you go to any
human society and ask about it
and there will be some game of
chance that they play at
the--that influences their
thinking.
The problem with--there's a
problem with gambling behavior
because in a certain fraction of
the population we have
pathological gambling.
One study estimated that 1.1%
of men and .5% of women,
for some reason more common
among men than women,
but in both sexes are
pathological gamblers.
That means it's like alcoholism;
they cannot control themselves
and it ruins their lives.
They get divorces because the
spouse complains that my husband
or wife gambled away all of our
money and that's bad,
but they can't stop themselves.
There's an organization called
Gambler's Anonymous,
which is like Alcoholic's
Anonymous.
It helps people who are really
in trouble.
This is a problem.
I think the financial industry
attracts people like that,
so you're overrepresented--If
people are not quite
pathological--people who are
stimulated somehow by chance;
that is a problem.
Magical thinking.
This refers--this actually goes
back to B.F.
Skinner, a psychologist who
flourished in the first half of
this century.
I actually had him as a
next-door neighbor.
It was a strange thing.
I was visiting Harvard and MIT
in Cambridge and I rented a
house and this guy was next
door.
He and I both used to walk into
work together--not together,
I never really met him,
but I always felt an affinity
to him.
He must have died twenty years
ago by now.
But anyway, he did a famous
experiment with pigeons which,
in the 1940s--1948--in which he
induced strange behavior
patterns in pigeons by the
following simple experiment.
The experiment was,
he would put--the pigeon was in
a cage and he'd let the pigeon
get pretty hungry--hungry
pigeons are not happy pigeons.
Then he had a machine that
granted each pigeon one piece of
corn every fifteen seconds;
that's very,
frustratingly slow for a hungry
pigeon to get one piece every
fifteen seconds.
Then he observed,
through time,
after subjecting pigeons to
this torture for some time--it
might be not approved by--it's
not really torture,
it's like dieting or something,
you've all lived through that,
right?
Semi-torture for a pigeon.
He noticed that the pigeons
started behaving in strange ways
and he kept them separate so
they couldn't learn from each
other.
One pigeon was jumping up and
down a lot, another one was
bobbing its head,
and another one was doing kind
of a little dance.
What he concluded was,
these pigeons were trying to
figure out what makes those
pieces of corn come and they
started to think--well,
they had to get the interval
between corns right to make this
work.
But he started--the pigeons
started to think,
effectively,
what was it I did just before
that last piece of corn came?
I was bobbing my head,
so maybe I better bob my head
again and sure enough another
piece of corn comes.
So, he started assuming that
what they were doing is making
the corn come.
But each one does a different
thing.
If they're all in isolation
they would all be doing
different things.
I think our financial markets
are like that.
That people--they develop some
investment strategy and through
pure chance it does well.
But they--because of over
confidence and magical thinking,
it starts to go to their ego.
They think, I'm really a smart
investor, I figured it out,;
it can reinforce the behavior
until they get to maybe some
terrible end.
It doesn't necessarily work out
as well.
B.F.
Skinner never let his pigeons
starve;
they all made it out alright.
There's something else called
quasi-magical thinking,
which was a term coined many
years later by Eldar Shafir and
Amos Tversky.
Shafir is a young psychologist
at Princeton who teamed up with
the old psychologist Tversky and
wrote this paper.
What it refers to is--people
get the impression that they can
control randomness.
Maybe the pigeons were thinking
that, maybe not,
we don't know;
Shafir and Tversky report
experiments with people,
not pigeons.
Quasi-magical thinking is an
illusion that they documented
that occurs regularly in people,
which they might deny if asked
about, but there's an illusion
that I can control randomness
through my willpower.
I won't talk about their
experiments, but I just want to
mention one by a Harvard
psychologist Ellen Langer.
I mentioned this before--I
think I mentioned it before--if
you say, I'm going to ask you to
bet on a coin toss.
There are two different ways of
doing it.
One is to say,
how much will you bet and then
I toss the coin.
The other way is,
I toss the coin first and I can
conceal the outcome and then I
ask, how much would you like to
bet?
Langer found that people want
to bet more if the coin hasn't
been tossed yet.
Why would that be--why would
you care?
It's still the same experiment.
It appears that people,
at some level,
think that they can exert
willpower over it and control
it.
This gives rise again to
overconfidence among investors.
It's also--another example,
which is relevant,
I don't know if any of you
voted yesterday.
Why do people vote?
Because an economic theory
would say that nobody ever
votes.
If we're all--conventional
economic theory says,
we're all relentlessly selfish
and calculating.
Isn't that what you've learned
in economics?
Well, maybe you didn't
necessarily but that is
economical theory.
If you're relentlessly selfish
and calculating you would say,
the chances that I decide the
election are zero,
so I'm just not going to
bother.
The question is--you must have
thought that,
right?
You know that you're not going
to decide the election,
so what does it matter?
If you can introspect and ask,
why is it that I vote?
I think that at least for many
of us, there is a sort of
logical conundrum we go through
and that is,
if good people don't vote then
we'll be in a bad world;
so I have to vote to prove that
good people vote,
then maybe it will happen.
If I'm a good person,
then other people will be good
persons.
This is magical thinking and it
affects people because it gives
them a sense of confidence and
power over events that are
thought to be random or
uncontrollable.
It can also be something that
can be exploited by some not so
nice people.
I want to talk about regulation.
The problem with finance is
that it's a beautiful--financial
institutions are beautiful
structures but they only are as
good as the people who use them.
The problem is that the history
of finance is the history of a
lot of people being exploited
and treated badly,
so there are temptations from
the market.
People who know human
psychology know that they can
exploit human weaknesses.
There's a temptation to
oversell investments.
That is, promise that they will
do well--you see this all the
time.
I was just seeing yesterday's
paper--someone was selling gold
coins.
Don't buy gold coins that you
might see--and you know that,
right?
There were words in there--they
said something--of course,
we cannot guarantee that they
won't go up in value but
historically they have always
done it or something like that.
They're trying to oversell.
You know that buying gold coins
from some newspaper ad is not a
smart investment,
but they know that there will
be people out there.
A recent example of
overselling: the National
Association of Realtors has been
running ads saying that home
prices have always doubled every
ten years.
They didn't word it that--they
put it in the present tense:
home prices double every ten
years.
That's an organization of
people who sell real estate and
they have ad campaigns trying to
convince you that home prices
are going to double.
That's overselling because
we're in a real estate crisis
and home prices are falling and
that's the kind of thing that
makes some people upset.
There's a tendency to hide
information.
You avoid telling people the
things that would discourage
them.
People have attention
anomalies, so they don't go out
and see all the information and
if you don't put it up front,
then they'll never find it.
There's a tendency for loyalty
to friends--that's your own
friends--and there's this word,
other people.
I think different languages
have different words for
this–-there are friends
and then there are all those
random people that we don't care
about.
So, investors will have a
tendency to try to hide--or
people who sell investments will
try to channel the good
investments to their friends and
dump the bad stuff on other
people.
That's what has been happening
a little bit--more than a little
bit--in the subprime crises.
We've managed to package
subprime loans that we
thought--some people
thought--were terrible and sell
them off to unwitting foreigners
who didn't know.
They thought that they were
getting good stuff.
There's also a tendency for
churning for commission.
This is a fault that real
estate brokers can make.
If they're paid by commission
on each trade they just keep
calling you up and coming up
with new ideas for new trades.
That's unethical behavior
because it--if you keep trading
too much, then you cannot
possibly make money.
The trading commissions will
eat up all of your profits and
professionals know that,
so it's bad behavior.
We have historically developed
regulations that deal with these
problems.
The only reason I believe that
we have financial markets that
work is because we have
regulations.
I'm going to talk primarily
about U.S.
regulations and give a little
history of them.
The U.S.
is actually an important
country for regulation because
it has been a model for much of
the regulations around the
world.
I'm going to give a kind of a
history of financial regulations
in the United States that makes
it rather a simple story.
The simple story is that
regulation mostly came in with
the Progressive Era at the
beginning of the century and
reached its culmination at the
time of the Great Depression and
set up a lot of institutions
that are still with us today.
Then there was deregulation,
which started around the 1970s,
and the events we've seen--that
we're seeing today--are outcomes
of both the regulation and the
deregulation.
I want to start out with the
origins of securities
regulation.
A critical point was a book
written by Louis Brandeis,
that's the guy that Brandeis
University is named after.
He was an author,
a lawyer, then Supreme Court
Justice, but he wrote a book in
1914 called Other People's
Money and it was very
influential.
I have it on reserve,
but that's not required for the
mid-term;
it's just if you're interested
in seeing it.
He believed that the most
important step for the
government in promoting better
financial markets is
disclosure--to force businesses
or financial businesses to
disclose the truth equally to
everybody.
His famous quote is,
"Sunshine is the best
disinfectant."
Sunshine, meaning the truth,
and everyone in the financial
industry has to just tell people
what they're doing.
He said it has to be really
disclosed and he likened it to
labeling.
They were already,
in 1914, starting to require
that food packages show
nutritional--or ingredients and
nutritional information.
It was on the package and he
thought, that's the kind of
model for the financial
industry.
The disclosure has to be made
convenient so that--it's not
like you can get the information
by going downtown to City Hall
and asking for it.
The principle is that you have
to require that the information
be given to the investor.
That was a very
important--Around the time of
this book, state regulators were
developing,
at the state government level
in the United States,
what they called Blue Sky Laws.
These were laws regulating how
securities are sold.
There are different theories
about why they call them Blue
Sky Laws.
I think it was because people
were overselling investments and
saying, there's no limit to this
investment but the blue sky
above.
The problem with the Blue Sky
Laws was that they were each
done separately and it was hard
for states to manage what were,
basically, national businesses.
So the Blue Sky Laws were
basically coming in the teens.
In the 1920s,
things changed because the
telephone first became widely
spread.
Until the teens,
telephones were very expensive
because they didn't have good
amplification technology.
But by the '20s,
everybody got a telephone in
their house and the average
person made hundreds of phone
calls a year,
so it was a big change in our
society, This led to the boiler
rooms--these were businesses
that called around on the
telephone and sold stocks--often
bogus stocks--in the 1920s.
The reason they call them
boiler rooms is,
if you are selling stocks by
telephone there's no reason to
rent a nice office,
so you get the cheapest--so you
put a whole bank of telephones
in the cheapest place.
That would be the basement of
some building where they have
the boiler.
So, you'd have a whole bunch of
people selling securities down
there and they could vacate
quickly if the authorities
challenged you.
In the 1920s,
a lot of bogus stuff was
sold--a lot of people were
cheated--so after the stock
market crash of 1929,
it led to a movement for
regulation.
The most important thing was
the 1934 foundation of the
Securities and Exchange
Commission--or SEC--which I
think,
ultimately dates back
to–it was really the
embodiment of Louis Brandeis'
principles.
This Securities and Exchange
Commission was an organization
that--I guess you could say its
principal structure--its
principal thing was to make sure
that disclosure was proper and
that people found it easy to get
the information about
securities.
The SEC was very controversial
at first because it was seen as
interfering with business and
the U.S.
has been built on principles of
individual freedom;
this seemed like unnecessary
government intrusion.
There was a hostile attitude
between business and the
original SEC.
Franklin Delano Roosevelt was
viewed as very left-wing by
business and very contrary to
American values.
But in fact,
the SEC promoted the very
free-market concepts that were
widely believed in this country.
Basically, what it did was it
made it feel that people
wouldn't get cheated;
the SEC was a strong regulator
and it really did restore
confidence in the financial
markets in this country.
Other countries--In Europe,
after the 1929 crash,
they had a different reaction
to the scandals and problems of
the '20s and it wasn't as
favorable to markets as in the
U.S.
The Securities and Exchange
Commission, from the beginning,
had it as its mission to make
financial markets work properly;
that is a wonderful story.
One of the first Chairmen of
the SEC was a man named William
O.
Douglas, who was actually a
Yale law professor.
I guess he influences me
because--I have on the reading
list--again it's an optional
reading,
but he has a book called
Democracy and Finance
1940 and what he advocated
again was that financial markets
have to be made to work for the
people.
I guess this influenced
me–actually,
in my 2003 book,
New Financial Order,
I talked about the
democratization of finance as a
fundamental principle.
We have to make finance work
for real people,
so for me that meant
understanding human frailties
and understanding human
psychology to make things work.
He was also a major figure in
the Legal Realism school that
recognized human failings and
human behavior and the
establishment of laws.
We have to realize that people
don't read all the fine print
and don't understand--if you
have a precisely written
contract in legal language,
maybe they don't get it.
One of the things that came out
and was firmly embodied into law
with the advent of the SEC.
There were precursors to this,
but the SEC forces the
difference between public and
private securities and this is a
very important distinction.
Public securities are
securities that the SEC will
accept as suitable for the
general public and private
securities are securities that
have not been vetted by the SEC
for the general public.
The SEC--you have to
decide--you hear about public
companies and private companies.
If you're a public company it
means that you've gone through
the procedures at the SEC to be
approved as a public company.
If you are a public company,
the important thing is you have
to do all of the disclosure that
Louis Brandeis would have liked;
you have to file regular forms
with the SEC,
disclosing information.
Public companies--these public
companies--if you want to get on
the SEC website,
go to sec.gov and then there is
a tab that you can click,
which is Edgar.
If you click on Edgar you can
enter the name of any public
company in the United States and
then all of its filings are
online and you can find out an
incredible amount of information
about companies.
It's all there,
as long as they're public
companies.
A public--a lot of companies
don't want to be public because
you can't keep secrets very
well;
you've got to regularly put
those things up online and
they're out there for everybody
to see.
Companies can choose whether to
be public or private.
Why do they choose to be public?
Well they--it's a
balancing--they have to
balance--sometimes they don't
like the choice they made but
the advantage to being public is
that people trust you more.
Moreover, your market is
bigger, so public companies have
an advantage;
so companies don't like to be
public, generally.
It's contrary to their
instincts.
We keep all sorts of secrets in
our company;
we don't want to be filing all
of our information all the time
and to have it go right up on
the website on standard forms so
that everyone can easily process
it.
They may swallow their doubts
because they have a sense that
it will improve the market for
their shares.
So we have a lot of public
companies.
Now, if you are a private
company, you are limited to
where you can sell your
investments.
Let's take an example of an
important kind of private
company, called a hedge fund.
If you are--this is a private
investment company--let's think
before we talk about
hedge--think of--suppose you're
a public investment company
approved by the SEC.
The problem with being a public
investment company is you have
to file quarterly reports about
all the things you've invested
in.
So you say, how can I make
money beating the market if
every quarter I have to tell
everybody what I'm doing?
A lot of investment companies
don't want to be public,
they want to be private so they
don't have to.
Hedge funds do not post their
investments on Edgar,
so they're private.
If you're a private company,
you're subject to regulation
that limits a lot of things you
can do.
Notably, you're not allowed to
advertise.
If you're a hedge fund,
you're not for the
public--you're not approved for
investing by the public.
So, what business do you have
to buy ads in newspapers
announcing yourself.
As a result,
hedge funds have a very low
profile.
It's not their choice--they
might like to advertise--but
they can't without running afoul
of the SEC.
They'll say,
you're behaving like a public
company and you're not public.
So, hedge funds do not
advertise, that's why people
don't know about them and they
have a mysterious--they sound
mysterious.
Moreover, very significantly,
they are limited in what kind
of investors they can take.
Now, there are different kinds
of hedge funds--there's a lot of
legal complexity here--but a 3c1
hedge fund is limited to
ninety-nine investors.
That's not very many people and
they must be accredited
investors.
You ask, what is an accredited
investor?
Well, if you want to find out
you can get onto sec.gov and it
will give you the current
definition.
I wonder how many of you are
accredited investors?
I would guess not many of you.
Here's how you become an
accredited investor:
(a) you have $1 million dollars
in investable--that's not
including your house,
it's in investable assets.
I won't ask for a show of hands.
(b) You're making at least
$200,000 a year,
or (c) if you're married,
you have to be a couple making
at least $300,000.
So, it's supposed to be for
rich people.
Incidentally,
they haven't raised the
definition of accredited
investors for many years.
Last year, the SEC put out a
proposal that--it's getting too
easy to be an accredited
investor--so they put out a
proposal that we raise the
wealth level to $2.5 million.
I thought they were going to
and that was to protect people
who might be naïve,
innocent people who only have a
million dollars or only have two
million dollars and don't know
what they're doing from hedge
funds.
But, it got shot down
apparently because it never
happened.
I think it's very hard to raise
the definition of accredited
investors because the minute you
do that you're closing large
numbers of people out from their
ability to invest in hedge funds
and they don't like that;
they feel insulted,
so there was a lot of angry
reaction.
There's also another kind of
hedge fund, 3c7,
which can take five hundred
investors.
If they register as a 3c7,
they can take more investors.
But then, they're limited to
qualified purchasers.
This is just an example of
their regulations.
A qualified purchaser has to
have at least $5 million dollars
or, if it's an institution,
at least $25 million--that is a
natural person.
A natural person refers to a
human being, so it's $5 million
for natural persons and $25
million for institutions.
So, if you're a small college
with only $20 million in a
portfolio you don't come across
as a qualified purchaser.
They're trying to protect
innocent, small colleges who
only have $20 million dollars.
The idea is that people who
don't have much money can't
afford expensive lawyers and
they can't figure it out and
they really shouldn't be
investing in hedge funds.
These public-private
distinctions are onerous--are
offensive--to some people
because it seems like the
government is acting like a
parent.
Most of the people are--if
you're not accredited as an
investor it's like the
government doesn't respect you;
it's like they're treating you
like children.
Why would it be that somebody
else is allowed to invest in a
hedge fund and I'm not?
It rankles, but on the other
hand, these regulations survive
because the reality is that
people are victimized all the
time and we can't just allow
companies to act in secrecy.
This is something that I
believe in--not everyone
believes in this--but the
general principle has been
now--ever since the 1930s--that
the general public is not
allowed to invest in things that
are not properly documented.
Another important distinction
in securities regulation is the
distinction between insider and
outsider.
An insider is someone who is
privy to the secret information
of a company and the secret
information could be used to
trade.
If you know the secrets of a
company, if you know some good
news about the company before
the public does,
you could buy the shares of the
company and experience the
profit when the price goes up.
You would be exploiting insider
information and you would be
victimizing the outsiders.
The idea, from the beginning at
the SEC, was that insiders
should not be allowed to trade
on information that is not
properly disclosed to the
public.
There was an important change:
Regulation F.D.
came in 2000.
F.D.
stands for full
disclosure--this is a SEC
regulation.
Regulation F.D.
was, I think,
passed in recognition of the
internet.
Under Louis Brandeis--Brandeis
wanted companies to always
present the information,
but for him it always meant
presenting a document,
so they had something called a
prospectus,
for example.
You could not sell a security
without giving a prospectus to
the potential buyers and the
prospectus would be something
approved by the SEC.
I don't know if the word is
approved but it's--you have to
run it by the SEC and then you
always have to give that up.
But he was living in the paper
age.
We now live in the internet age
and so Regulation F.D.--I don't
know if it actually mentions the
internet but it's--the
Regulation F.D.
basically says that whenever a
company announces information it
has to be available almost
instantly to everybody in the
market.
So, the way it has worked out
in practice is that companies,
when they have a major
announcement to make,
they have some kind of web
event.
Anybody in the world--they
would be notified and they could
get on and hear it as it's
happening.
So we have meetings--big
meetings--on the web for
disclosure of important
information.
This has made it very clear
that there has to be--if you
announce anything you have to
announce it all at once on a
certain date and you can't have
favored people that you give the
announcement to.
Market surveillance is a
process that stock exchanges and
other organizations do to make
sure that inside information is
not being mishandled.
The self-regulatory
organizations,
SROs, are industry
organizations that regulate the
industry.
That's the American way of
doing things.
Rather than have the government
regulate, we have an industry
organization that does it so
that the government doesn't have
to.
The SROs have complex
regulatory equipment,
computers that can discover
insider trading and the SROs
will catch you or they may catch
you if you try.
I want to give you an example
of SRO behavior and this is just
one news story.
It was in 1995,
a secretary at IBM Corporation
was asked to xerox some
documents by her boss and the
documents described a proposed
takeover of Lotus Corporation.
Remember Lotus?
That was the corporation that
produced the first spreadsheet
program.
It's now been replaced mostly
by Microsoft Excel.
But at the time it was big,
so this was big news.
IBM is going to take over Lotus
or try to take over Lotus.
We now know what happened
because of the surveillance
investigation.
She told her husband that she
had just Xeroxed this thing--she
had read what she was
Xeroxing--and she told her
husband who was a beeper
salesman about the news.
He did nothing except tell two
friends the story--he didn't buy
shares, he just told two
friends, my wife says that IBM
is going to take over Lotus.
The friends immediately bought
Lotus shares and then--that was
June 2--by June 5,
twenty-five people had
bought--had spent a half a
million dollars to buy on this
tip.
They included a pizza chef,
an electrical engineer,
a bank executive,
a dairy wholesaler,
a school teacher and four
stockbrokers;
stockbrokers get the word
faster.
Guess what happened?
Those people are all in trouble
because it's illegal to trade on
insider information and they
tracked them all down.
I'll give you another example
and this is the example of
Emulex Corporation.
Maybe this isn't exactly
insider trading,
this is more fraud but in--what
year was this?
Around sometime in the late
'90s, Mark Jacob--he's the
criminal here,
he's probably out of jail now.
Mark Jacob was upset with--he
had been an employee of Emulex
and had access to inside
information of the company.
I guess he was involved in the
dissemination of information for
the company, so he kind of knew
how they did press releases.
So he sent out a fake--he
bought--he shorted the company
and he--the stock in the
company--and he bought--he put
out a fake press release saying
that there was bad news for the
company.
He knew how to make it look one
of Emulex's press releases.
He also did it from the El
Camino Community College Library
because he thought,
I'll be careful,
I won't issue this fake press
release on my own computer
because they might be able to
track me back to my own
computer.
So, he went to this community
college and got one of their
library computers and he issued
the press release there.
He got picked up by all the
major news services,
the stock plummeted,
he sold immediately and he made
a lot of money.
The problem is, it didn't work.
They tracked back who sold--who
shorted and who had sold just
before--just at that time.
They also went back to the El
Camino Community College Library
and they interviewed the
librarians and tried to ask
them,
do you remember somebody coming
here that didn't look like a
student?
They identified him and he was
caught.
That's what surveillance does.
They make the markets work
because if you didn't have this
there would be all kinds of
crooks and bad actors.
The thing about these
organizations is that they cost
money and they cause nuisances.
A lot of people in the
financial community are annoyed
by them because these
regulations are costly to comply
with and they take a lot of
resources.
I think the enlightened view is
that these things are absolutely
essential to trust in the
market.
Another form of regulation is
accounting regulation.
For example,
we have in the United States
the Financial Accounting
Standards Board--it's right here
in Connecticut--or FASB.
This is not a government
organization.
It was organized by the SEC in
1973, but the SEC didn't want to
do this job;
they wanted it to be done
privately.
What FASB does for the United
States is it creates what are
called Generally Accepted
Accounting Practices.
They're rules for how a company
should keep its books so that
there's some regularity and
standards in how accounting is
done.
When the Financial Accounting
Standards Board listens to what
corporations are saying and
helps them--it adjusts these
standards from time to time but
it does have definitions that
have to be maintained.
A company has a profit and loss
statement and there's something
that is called net income,
which is the measure of how
much the company is making--the
profits after expenses of the
company,
called the bottom line.
The GAAP standards define this.
There's also operating income.
Now, companies can use other
definitions of--other accounting
standards besides these and some
of these other definitions,
which are not always
GAAP--other standards--and are
widely used in the industry are
other kinds of--they have what's
called core earnings,
pro forma earnings,
EBITDA, which is earnings
before interest,
taxes, depreciation,
and amortization.
Adjusted earnings.
There are all kinds of
different definitions and
companies like to do it their
own way because they want to
present themselves in the best
way to the public.
But they're not allowed to just
do it their own way;
they have to do it according to
standards, so the GAAP
accounting is standardized.
What a company can do is
present things in two different
ways.
They can present GAAP and then
that goes to Edgar and they can
also present it any other way
they like.
But the law--the SEC requires
that they at least present the
standard earnings definitions
for all these things.
Now another--let me just
mention off balance sheet
accounting.
The one thing that the SEC
requires that companies file is
their balance sheet,
which you can look up for any
company on Edgar.
The balance sheet of a company
has two columns;
it has assets and it has
liabilities.
So, on one side is everything
the company owns and the other
side is everything the company
owes.
The net worth of the company is
their assets minus their
liabilities and that represents
the value that the company has
if they paid off all their
liabilities.
What the SEC has to worry about
is something called off balance
sheet accounting,
which occurs when companies try
to hide some of the things that
they--the liabilities that they
have by not recording them on
the balance sheet.
If you can get away with that
then you can do--you can conceal
maybe some risky investments
you've made or some leverage
that you've had.
You might have brought in
investments or something by
borrowing money,
so the investment--the combined
investment and liability--could
be very volatile.
You don't want people to know
that, so you don't put it on the
balance sheet.
The SEC and other regulators
have to watch for this.
The classic example of a
company that did this--it's a
classic now--is Enron
Corporation.
They had a number of
partnerships that they put on as
off balance sheet.
They were making risky
investments but they weren't
reporting them properly on the
SEC forms, so people didn't know
how risky Enron was.
More recently--this came out
last year--the SIVs,
so called structured investment
vehicles,
were used by banks to cover up
investments they had,
often in risky subprime loans.
Well, they created special
entities called SIVs and the
SIVs would be borrowing money on
the commercial paper market to
buy subprime loans.
They were in a very risky
position because subprime loans
were already recognized as being
risky.
They'd borrow to buy them,
so if the value of the subprime
loans went down just a little
bit the SIV would be in trouble.
In the SIV contract,
there was some language that
implied that if the SIV ever
went bankrupt,
the bank would come back and
rescue them.
The SIV really was a liability
but it wasn't visible to
investors investing in the bank.
This is another example of off
balance sheet accounting that
was frustrating the rules of the
SEC.
I wanted to talk about another
instance of regulation that is
important in the United States
but it's very poorly known.
We have something called SIPC,
that's the Securities Investor
Protection Corporation,
which was created in 1970.
This is the securities' analog
of the FDIC in banking.
I don't know if I mentioned--I
assume you know about the
Federal Deposit Insurance
Corporation?
I thought that was better-known.
Well, let me just mention it by
analogy.
In 1934, after the failure--it
was actually created by Congress
in 1933 and went into business
in '34.
The FDIC, Federal Deposit
Insurance Corporation--I'll put
it down as 1934--guaranteed for
small depositors the savings
deposits they had at a bank.
That was to protect depositors
in the case of bank failure and
it was a very important
innovation because,
at that time,
there were huge runs on banks.
People were pulling money out
of banks because they feared
that if the bank failed,
then they would lose their
money;
it created a huge crisis in
1933.
It's for small investors
because currently the limit on
the SEC is $100,000;
that's not a lot of money.
Maybe you think of it as a lot
of money, but it's not.
If someone's saving for their
retirement you better have a lot
more than that;
$100,000 is only a few years of
income even for low-income
people.
At least we want to protect the
small investors' savings in
banks.
Actually, if you have more than
$100,000 in a bank account you
should probably pull it out and
spread it around over several
banks because each bank is
separately insured,
so there's effectively no limit
if you're just a little bit
smart and move your accounts
around.
We had deposit insurance
starting in The Great Depression
and that's been very important;
it's now in every country.
We had a run on a bank in the
UK, it was called Northern Rock,
last year.
It turns out that there was a
failure of the UK deposit--I
would say it's a failure because
UK deposit insurance insured
Northern Rock only for the first
£3,000.
Then for the next--I forget how
many thousand pounds--you were
90% insured so that was not good
enough because people were
worried about losing 10% of
their deposits.
So there was a big bank run and
Northern Rock would have failed
if the Bank of England hadn't
come by to rescue them.
I think that deposit insurance
is very important but we didn't
have anything for corresponding
accounts at brokerage services
until 1970 This was motivated by
a spectacular failure of a
brokerage,
Goodbody & Co., in 1970.
I hope you know what I mean;
a brokerage service is a place
where stockbrokers work and a
stockbroker is somebody that
manages your buying and selling
of shares.
So if you want to buy stock you
can call the stockbroker.
Merrill Lynch is a big retail
broker--they're right down here
on the Green.
You can go there and say,
I want to buy stocks,
and the broker will say fine,
we'll set up an account for
you.
You've deposited money in our
account–now,
he's not a bank,
he's a broker--we'll set up a
cash account and a securities
account.
Put some money in and then you
think about it and then you call
me up and say,
do you want to buy some stocks.
Then I'll take money out of
your cash account and I'll put
it into these securities.
That's a broker.
Goodbody &
Company was a broker,
but it failed in 1970--it went
bankrupt--and then it looked
like the people who had money
and shares in them would lose.
There are two things:
you can have a cash account
with them--you put money into
the cash account and you haven't
bought shares with it yet;
it's just sitting--it's like in
a bank.
You could lose that because
Goodbody &
Company is going bankrupt;
it doesn't have it anymore.
Well, what about your shares?
Well, Goodbody &
Company is supposed to have
your shares but they generally
hold them in what's called
"street name."
That means Goodbody &
Company owns the shares and you
just have a contractual
relationship with Goodbody that,
in principle,
some of those shares are yours.
But the company that you're
investing in ultimately doesn't
have your money.
It's Goodbody that they're
dealing with,
although they have ways of--for
a proxy--and they have ways of
finding out who's who.
The problem is,
if your brokerage firm fails
you could lose a lot;
you could lose your cash
account and your security
account.
So, SIPC was set up in 1970 and
SIPC insures cash accounts up to
$100,000 and securities accounts
up to $500,000.
That's another example of
government involvement.
SIPC was set up by an act of
Congress.
So the–unfortunately,
I don't know--have you ever
heard of SIPC?
Most people don't even know it
exists.
SIPC did a survey of the U.S.
population and this is one of
the--In 2001,
this is one of the questions
SIPC asked.
The respondents were asked to
identify the organization that
insures you against losing money
in the stock market or as the
result of investment fraud.
Only 16% of investors knew that
there is no such company.
Let me make this clear,
SIPC does not--if you invest in
some stock and it does badly you
can't go to SIPC and say,
hey my stocks went down please
give me my money back.
They won't do it.
Moreover, if you say,
this stockbroker he was lying
to me, he told me that this was
a good investment and he even
lied and said something to get
me roped in,
they won't pay you back.
The only thing that SIPC does
is replace securities.
In other words,
if you had an account at a
brokerage and you thought you
had a hundred shares of IBM and
now the broker is going
bankrupt--the broker won't
answer your email anymore and
he's just gone--you go to SIPC
and say,
I had these hundred shares.
SIPC than returns a hundred
shares to you;
they don't pay you cash.
They give you the hundred
shares and that's all they do.
You might say that our
regulation hasn't gone far
enough and I think maybe it
hasn't gone far enough.
We protect certain kinds of
things and people have to pay
attention.
It's a difficult problem that
not everyone is smart--they vary
in their ability--so we try to
make a world in which it's
pretty safe for the small
investor who's not paying
attention.
It's never perfect and we can't
figure out yet a way to make it
perfect and we still have small
investors who are defrauded,
who are treated badly.
The subprime crisis is an
example: some people were
treated badly in this recent
financial crisis.
So, we just have to keep
improving our regulation and
trying to make a deal with all
of the problems as they come up.
The problems are complex
because we're trying to make a
system in which people are able
to make their own decisions as
much as possible and to make
them in a way that--in an
environment that they trust.
But it's just too complicated
and too--it's impossible to make
it work perfectly.
So, that will conclude this
lecture.
So I'll--I won't be here Monday
but my T.A.'s will handle the
exam and I'll see you on
Wednesday.